a search for two children from Idaho has
taken an alarming turn their parents are
now missing too and the FBI thinks the
kids are in serious danger
seven-year-old Joshua JJ valo and 17
year old Ty Lee Ryan haven't been seen
for three months police believe their
mother Laurie valo and stepfather
Chad de Bell could have answers if they
can be found investigators say the
children's disappearance could be
connected to the death of de belles
former wife Erin Burnett is following
this story
Erol bizarre doesn't even begin to
describe it's just this story you're
absolutely right it's bizarre there are
twists and turns and police now are
asking for for anyone's help who may
have information so listen up you may
know something police say the parents
were uncooperative when trying to find
the children and that was before the
parents vanished
this is JJ valo singing on a bus with
his grandfather six months before he
disappeared the seven-year-old with
autism and his sister Ty Lee Ryan were
last seen in Rexburg Idaho on September
23rd investigators only discovered they
were missing when another case was
cracked wide open a librarian in town
Tammy de Bell died in her home October
19th she was initially thought to have
died of natural causes but in a later
investigation the local sheriff's office
determined her death might be suspicious
her body was exhumed for an autopsy and
those results are pending her widower
Chad de Bell got remarried within just a
few weeks - a woman named Laurie valo
the mother of the missing children and
in the course of investigating Tammy de
belles death police were made aware of
the missing kids concerned relatives
reached out to police after not hearing
from JJ for weeks investigators
performed a welfare check at Laurie
Veloz home in late November and
according to police she and Chad de Bell
said JJ was staying with a family friend
in Arizona but when investigators
returned the next day with search
warrants valo and de bel were gone
why they're doing what they're doing it
doesn't make any sense according to
local TV station KS tu Brandon Boudreaux
used to be married to Lori fallows nice
and even baptized Ty Lee Ryan
he says valo and de bel have cult-like
religious beliefs and he feels that may
be playing a role I don't know what
happened to those kids I know that
there's people who do when they're not
talking and I know it's tough to follow
but there's more investigators are also
reportedly looking into Lori Veloz
ex-husband's death her ex-husband was
killed by her brother that brother is
now also dead police are urging anyone
who may know about the whereabouts of
the missing children to immediately call
9-1-1 this as a case stretching from
Utah to Arizona and as you've just seen
very complicated I mean it sounds like a
48-hour mystery and it is there's so
many layers to it and the missing
children at there at the center of all
this the young boy has autism and police
are imploring everyone the FBI is
involved in this as well to contact the
Center for Missing and Exploited
Children if you know anything that's
connected to this Mis just really
absolutely just want those kids to be ok
right Thank You Errol very much
appreciate it
you